ハーイという沖縄から帰ってきたんですけども
あのお知らせがあります8動画のタイトルの通り
しばらく動画をお休みさせていただきます
今までありがとうございましたやめねーけどなあまあ辞めないんですけどもうセレナの
ちょっとスケジュールがいっぱいいっぱいすぎて動画を出す時間が全くございません
ってなんか最近てがもう年拙書いうね3月の後半からもう忙しすぎて正直
のメインの動画に割く時間がないんですよやばぺねえもんだか本末転倒
効果はあるんですけども
マーサーないですからないことだと思って部活とぐっと今堪えず得るところであったん
ですけどもう何かこらえてるのもうちょっともういいやと思っちゃってなんか中途半端
に忙しくてなんか無理やりどうぞ出すぐらいだったらもう休もうと思って1週間ほど
ちょっと動画お休みさせていただきます
まあいろんなや理由があるんですけどもう前でもうもつれは
ますよ何なもやりたい道が山ほどあるんですけどゲーム時間がない
はいトレカ忙しいかと言いますとねこれが3月末のスケジュールなんですよ
まあ序盤がちょっとままあえてたりしたんですけども後半からおやおや
親父って感じでも怒涛の撮影スケジュール撮影や利便たらミーティングなら僕がメイン
の動画を取る以外のことがここに書いてあるんですけどもね色んな朝に行ったりですね
撮影したりミーティングしたりで
3月の後半からね27しか休みがなかったのかな
4月もえっと567初吸気口頭が色々と思うんですけどもそこからまた同党が
スケジュールで今が21日でもうこの先ですね二十一二十二2320二十五二十六
二十七二十八までノンストップでちょっと忙しすぎて無理
て動画とるぐらいだったらもう素直にあきらめるということでい中間
動画以外のことを頑張らせていただきます山グレコのスケジュール改めて見たんです
けど見ても3月4月ビルトをマッサー
私どういうスケジュールをとっているかといいますとこの青いスケジュールをちょっと
でもこれだけじゃなきゃいけないでやってそんなものは余った時間で畑の動画を取り
メンバーが鳥ってやってると叩きはみんな人がいるから
巨大別に取れたペックを取っちゃうと
メインの時間がねぇ
ないんですもうなんてそもそも毎日どうぞを出すこと自体不可能なんじゃねーかって
思ってたんですけどちょっとゴールデンウィークは動画だすたいなと思ってるんで
ゴールでメイク前のまあこの1週間かなぁ畑とはちゃんと出てると思うんですけどまぁ
メインはちょっとね自分やった事っていう
ってちゃんとやりたいんで眠りに動画を出してがっかりしてもらうのも嫌なんで
ちょっとしっかりと1週間えっと活動休止に立ってめっちゃ活動はするね
何でも活動はバンバンするんですけどメインチャンネルの動画投稿はちょっとストップ
させていただきます
2と販売の時間でできるものでもないと思うのでこういうことになってくるわけですよ
輸注ばちょっと
をまあこれが良いか悪いかというと僕はありがたいことであるんですけども良いと思っ
てないんで
動画出せない音はいけないそう最近後ネットだしたんですよね
なんか30発動の熱出したんでなんかちょっとメディちゃダメだろ
と思ってるんでちょっとしっかりとここは目の前にある仕事を丁寧にこなしていきたい
とおもいます
困ったから動画出せない困ったなぁ
まぁ一応ではそういうちゃんと理由があるので大丈夫だと思うんすけどせません
ちょっと僕忙しいんですよ
でも忙しいアビリットわけじゃなくて前世になんで忙しいかって輸入はあの子の通り
ですっていう
1週間たってもいつもどおり使ってるんですけどもすいませんちょっとこの1週間が
別途別のお仕事に集中させてください
もちろんそんな彼にどうとかもあるんですけどという感じでございます人がサービスと
したくないんですけどこれた牧場で忙しいアピールしないとみんな絶対はじめさぼっ
てんじゃん
ゲームとカードに遊んでんだろうなーって言われるんで
言わざるを得ないんでちゃんとビューとして言わせていただきます
たというわけでみなさん1週間後にお会いしましょう
しばしのお別れです by まいマー
東京いていきますぴょん
[音楽]
me
バッハ